primero quería decir gracias por
conectarme
y acabo de hablar otra vez con mis
familiares mis relativos y bueno algunos
tíos tías y todos dejaron casas ya
alexandriata no está seguro para vivir
bueno sus casos sus casas fueran en
casas nuevas recién hechas digamos en
los últimos años ahora viven en un
pueblo cerca
y un poco más de altitud de alexanderta
que es una ciudad de Costa ahora qué
medidas han decidido tomar sus
familiares permanecerán en la ciudad o
van a moverse a otros sitios más seguros
Bueno por el momento no han llegado
ningún tipo de ayuda desde el estado
el terremoto sea afectado diez
provincias y a la que la provincia de de
incluida
Mi ciudad natal alexandreta es muy cerca
Siria y Bueno todavía no ha llegado
hay ayudas oficiales digamos
no han llegado a las ayudas oficiales
hasta allí pero les han dicho si de
pronto tienen que trasladarse hacia otro
lugar para poder recibir este tipo de
ayudas
por lo que entendido toda toda la ciudad
está fuera de de sus casas
Y cuénteme si han seguido o han seguido
presentándose réplicas en esta región
Desde hace dos meses estamos viendo
terremotos pequeños de tipo cuatro
o tres tres punto dos cuatro punto dos
etcétera Pero no esperaban en un
terremoto de este este digamos este
magnitud Cuál es el llamado que ustedes
les hacen no solo a las autoridades
turcas sino también a la comunidad
internacional ante esta situación
Por lo que entendido todavía no ha
llegado la ayuda de la comunidad
internacional tampoco
y la ayuda está organizada y
no O estamos manejada por por un por una
agencia de desastre pertenece al estado
y por lo que he entendido Pues
también
las las municipalidades de otras
regiones de Turquía también que mandan
ayudas y todo el mundo está en Estambul
también está movilizado para mandar
ayudas a la región que es una región muy
miren aquí van los hoy con el testimonio
de lo que está sucediendo en ese momento
en Turquía luego del potente terremoto
que azotó al país y también afectó a
Siria Muchas gracias por este por este